all your favorite instagram influencers
marvel superheroes
have been drinking the kool-aid
master chief johnny bravo goku
they're all on steroids i feel like if
you mention this a lot of people will go
well obviously duh like everyone in the
fitness bubble knows it but if you think
about
in general how many people know about
steroid usage and how common it is i
don't think i don't i don't know do
people know i don't know i didn't used
to know and i worked out
you tell someone that doesn't lift that
the rock is on most likely on steroids i
mean the guy's guys like what he's
approaching 50 years to pack that kind
of muscle uh
even with steroids you know it's it's
damn impressive what he's able to
accomplish and the response is no he
puts in the work he puts in the hours
okay yeah no obviously that's what i'm
saying but i'm also saying he dips his
fingers in the vitamin gummy bear jar
maybe he takes two maybe even takes
three gummy bears who knows we don't
know because he doesn't talk about it
that's the whole point
there's no transparency and that's why i
think it's important and not to you know
make myself high and mighty but i do
think it's important for someone like me
who has an audience that isn't
necessarily into fitness to bring
attention to this kind of thing because
what i find is that in the industry it
seems like most people in some way are
engaging with steroids everyone sees it
it's obvious to all these people but a
lot of people don't know about it you
even get people saying like arnold he
never did steroids what are you talking
about like bro he openly talks about it
you just can't get that physique if it
looks unnatural it is unnatural that's a
good
and if you think that you know this kind
of steroid use is the thing of the past
i got bad news for you it's probably
more prevalent than ever you go on
instagram and you got 18 year olds
looking like [ __ ] orcs
again if
if it ain't looking natural it ain't
natural and i don't even necessarily
have a problem with it it is the lack of
transparency that i have an issue with
especially when these instagram
influencers are selling their epic
workout routines bro just use my code
and you can also look like me like shut
the [ __ ] up but what i do find as well
luckily is that a lot of great lifters
and a lot of youtubers are open about
talking about these things this guy noel
made this video
which you might have seen it kind of
went viral i think i am not a natural
bodybuilder and i have a major problem
with other influences that are not as
transparent about it not only does it
create false hope through naturally
unattainable results it discourages many
people from changing their lives it also
risks people's health for their
financial gain these same influences
enrich their lives by promoting and
selling you their diet and training
plans making it seem naturally
attainable to reach their chemically
enhanced physiques when it's not
hell yeah man yeah i think he summarized
it that's pretty much my whole point of
the video
but actually i think what bothers me the
most is that the people that really
really should be honest because the
thing is there's always going to be
instagram scumbags the the whole uh
concept behind selling them ideas to
improve their their bodies and
i don't know in any way
it's existed forever it feels like but
you have companies like disney and
marvel producing these superheroes
expanding their muscles to fit the part
in a very short amount of time and i
think uh to start off chris hemsworth is
a great example he's an absolute
beefcake can you even be mad at him for
using steroids like people want to see
him big you see all the comments on this
instagram post and like i can't wait to
can see how big your muscles are on thor
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome like can
you really blame him
actors and entertainers put their health
aside for the sake of entertainment we
want it they provide it you know can you
really be mad about it but what i don't
like about chris especially is that he's
selling this app uh where here it looks
natural by the way that's perfectly
attainable
train eat and live better with chris
hemsworth's team like what
i have to pay i gotta pay monthly to get
his workout routine like
out of here am i missing something here
like how many teenage marvel fans do you
think are buying this just hoping to
look like chris like they're they're
clearly selling the id like to play
devil's advocate i'm sure you know there
are some good works i work out in there
i haven't tried this app i'm not going
to but the whole selling point is you
know they want to look like chris and i
can even see myself as a teenager if i
was young saying this i would totally
buy into that and it's just lame dude
like we know the reason why you put that
physique to the next level and it's not
just putting the work putting the hours
okay here's him uh posting about on his
instagram about his trainer i know what
is this it's done it's not man bro come
on get out of here
everyone is just making fun of them as
well in the comments
like it's so obviously steroid use
i'm just wondering if they will also
provide the specific drug dosages and
intervals needed for headswords to look
like this it's fine to live but let's
stop acting like the marvel heroes
aren't juiced to the gills thank you our
second
marvel boy is kamal who had a huge
transformation
he did this transformation in a year
according to
the news articles
like even on steroids that's impressive
as hell because
anyone transforming in a year that's a
dead giveaway okay
like building muscle takes time it's a
slow process
and i can i at least understand you know
you get the role for
this superhero thing they have to fit
the part they need to gain muscle in a
really uh short amount of time how do
you do that well there's one secret
sauce and it's getting steroids to build
muscle i don't know why he looks goofier
in the movie i don't know how that's
even possible now after the movie looks
like he kept it going dude look at this
get the guy look at me
dude get the hell out of here
stop it i feel like people also again
defend this and be like well you know
he's got uh the best trainers in the
industry and he's got probably uh
the best nutrition as well that's how
he's able to pull that up yes yes but
he's also got the guy feeding him that
you know the steroids that
hit him just right but uh let's just
talk about these two
okay
i i think he he got so ripped that even
people that know about steroid usage
will be like well if i had to use
steroids to look like this what's the
[ __ ] point well then you're working
out for the wrong reason and that's
ridiculous but anyway the truth is
steroids work incredibly well yes you
still have to put in the work you have
to put in the hour you need to know what
to eat these are essential to growing
muscle but if this guy was natural
and this is what he was able to
accomplish in a year if he then put on
steroids on top of this he wouldn't be
able to move
cyrus is so affected that data shows
that you grow more muscle and i didn't
even know this you can grow more muscle
by not working out on steroids than
someone working out regularly if
if you ever want to feel discouraged
about working out hey keep that one in
mind
and i don't want to go into you know is
it is it good is it bad my whole point
about this video is the lack of
transparency and i really do have an
issue with it but i do think it's worth
mentioning that the side effects of
steroid usage is real okay it's not good
for you i don't care what anyone says
and what's the point anyway i love this
tweet summarizing it motherfu doing
steroids not even for a sport just to be
a swole ass waiter
so even though actors like camille isn't
necessarily selling any products like
chris hemsworth is he is still selling
this idea and as part of hollywood the
way it works if you're promoting
something you have to do all this media
for it what he did as part of his
promotion is he went to men's health and
they did a video showing what's in his
gym and his fridge he talks about
drinking beet juice guys you just have
to drink beet juice are you eating
enough protein that's just what you like
what are we kidding here it feels so
stupid it's like they're trying to come
up with every reason they can find to
hide the fact that they're on steroids
like they even go through some sort of
electroshock thing like is this a joke
this feels like a comedy sketch no i'm
not sarah
i electrocute my biceps
bro just own up to it [ __ ] uh mark
wahlberg you want to look like mark
wahlberg the man's 50 dude all you have
to do is wake up at 4 am that's the
secret like i'm not trying to downplay
people's hard work like all of these
actors would be
way more ripped than i am even without
steroids i i just don't like this facade
of i'm just i just had to drink like
these eggs
and i have to work out really hard and
like shut the [ __ ] up i remember when
robert pattinson was announced that he
was going to be batman uh he made
some interview
saying that he didn't want to work out
to become batman i even i had the
reaction of like that's ridiculous bro
you're going to be a superhero you have
to work out [ __ ] come on robert soyboy
beta now that i understand how the
industry works and what the expectations
are when you accept these rules maybe
i'm putting words in robert's mouth i
don't know if i do i'm sorry but the way
i understand this now is you obviously
can't mention anything about steroids
because then all these companies are
gonna
start calling you and kick you out of
their i don't know you're not gonna get
another acting job let's just put it
that way so now when he says i think if
you're working out uh all the time
you're part of the problem the way i
interpret him saying i don't want to
work out for batman is i don't want to
do steroids and i don't like the message
that that sends to people that's how i
read into that i don't know i could be
wrong and i guess that's the thing like
i don't know who's that right or wrong
here are we am i supposed to be mad at
chris and camille and all these marvel
people that after all they are just
giving people what they want which is
seeing these peop actors transform in
cinema are we at fault for having these
expectations and lashing them out to
other people i don't know what the right
answers is i think it's great that
influencers and lifters and anyone being
transparent about their usage is great
takes balls and a lot of people just
will respect you more for it but people
aren't going to be transparent because
there are this pressure from companies
to keep quiet and make us money you know
and that's why i think it's important to
talk about these things educate people
maybe who aren't even part of these
communities but you still engage with it
by just looking at it it affects your
subconsciousness and how you perceive
yourself and you compare yourself
whether you like it or not to these
people
getting fit takes time there's nothing
wrong with that don't compare yourself
to these people because they're probably
lying to you anyway that's it